The
next excerpt is taken from original tape W two twenty
one of the places
the tempo.
Run cheaper on. Upon Time for
a kick the cat and I don't
see why I can plumage.
You know the friendly restamp teams and only ours have the only kid to take the little kids
read
down. And one read that one team would run in the other and I'd have
to find by Niemi Arrow
isn't that true. And or we even grow a
spine you Ronit in a crisis then it wasn't it wasn't on top like it is or
not we had more empty life to hide in vibrations and stuff but now
you have to really go out to find someplace died and actually hidden some of these giant mice an oppressive
stark thing you're
trespassing so but then there wasn't it wasn't nearly back up and I got it on
her Saturn step right to hit a tree there wasn't much beyond the street to bring
cars past fact a member of people rock and I at once said about us that their car was to put him
in pasture Arkwright right now is a bond second trip
school so and when I was young they used to bring cars out there to pasture
to school but only now that we had a car when I was little.
It will. Yeah we have done.
I think we are calling to mind Dad bad I was eight years old on my dad bad so that was twenty four and
eight thirty two years.
He didn't use the opportunity
to purge. The humor of any of the right in
the middle I would be
the one.
You
mentioned divisive the rest of the.
You know I've never had a bicycle. I had a pilot from one of our neighbors.
My girlfriend and I neither one of us had a bicycle she was a foster child and of course I was but my dad
was debts we step to pay a dime. To rent the best support on the place and we have
to let them ride it up to the theater and we picked it up there and then we drive it until
we knew the show was over and then we'd have to bring it back to the show
and they use our van to run to the show and then they'd ride the bike on with after that.
I don't
know.
Simply put. Not too much because an encore left came from
the live three miles from here in Houston. Kim stated our host. And he's never
cried repair garage for
cars and he used to have a credit hour in there playing cards and I can remember.
Alright we just had abstract more than fixed at the time so we slept in the front turn
up and called my sister and
I and my mom called and his friends would be in the
kitchen bankcards around around to about and I can still hear certain that flew around
her drawers mirror. Whenever I mean those cards because that I think
I heard so much of these guys playing that they never really impressed me to
play cards I just thought it was a big waste
of time.
So when you know.
I never liked them and I still don't.
So I don't hear the shooter which
was. At times like here
in the winter time it's winter time trying time to watch
T.V. I sit next and watch T.V. but otherwise
not to the people. I
don't know do I know. They're all pretty
nice operator all the same I think I like. Name that
tune or something that somebody is using their musical talent to name all
the songs
or something because I can't remember names so I think I'm impressed when somebody
our young can remember songs from way back you know that I think
or by Remember that and I like it but I never remember the name of it you know. But
otherwise not
really. And I'm sure that sounds good
on
those grounds and then
that's And then they compete against each other and then it's ten thousand dollars
if you. If you win and it's
on two nights a week or one night only
rest is
good but it takes them a couple weeks to do
it against the fence and
all
those I'm less of an ace ten thousand bad when they really
are to me but you just literally
went to
the ground making sure that rhyme
like we had a housekeeper too I have to get the maids in to do the
cleaning depending on how many rooms we have how many men to call and
make sure that the laundry is
done. Make sure that their reservations are
kept in their daily report to do and then the night has and I got it
and shipped it has something but during the day shift you're busy more with checking out
then checking and. The people usually check in at night and then I have to check them out in the morning with
a major
report calling and the maids doing their
work and make sure that the keep their ad weekly and
then. So now we have the bass on here to us so we have
our tickets sounding and package sending and the Chamber offices here
but a
quest to grab a ten thousand steps when they go like not in the afternoon if their telephone
rang I would have to answer
some sort kind of a combination of more. Best friends.
All
you want to hide if you are real busy and I
don't think we get much busier than a motel car. We might have to have somebody come in
and answer
the phone and sell the tickets for the bass. Because when you're in a motel your guests are first and
if
you're. Trying to answer some of these questions on the telephone and are past their jobs
and somebody wants to check the N.R. check out. You can keep calling on their way time on
the phone for the subject keeps getting busy like it is right now we
might have to get somebody
and read about that legacy special we have only two buses going in the city.
So at least we had an hour before an hour after so they could sell the tickets or
something but that's just something that we're not now likely that arrives
the heart of the cigarettes and out of the supply
then so don't ever stop and make sure they're not ways.
Now or not it's kind of interesting. We'll do. One of the nicest chaps I've
ever had
I. Mentally made them work and a little bit harder
but this is the easiest physical job I've ever had
with her never throw Gibson's skirts the goods and
I was kind of manager that I don't know they call your manager but you're not we
are under the hood being a star so I don't know what do
you manage around a manager but your to an
assistant sure they had one in the App Store that you didn't have the capacity to do that most
managers do it.
We're just
grab fast track I already started to break into it I kinda like you know
I never went to college just graduated from high school now rest in the factories during
the when I was in Detroit. I ran thread now
machine. Inspections.
Put the tribe
screws. It's awfully hard
to put a different sizes in Crescent and star aka star after just a
little run and then I don't really like that because that was a really fast
that you do on ten
member about a big amount and run an hour. It was kind of
the present piece for better at reading both expected you to make so
many screws an hour and then as you crack better then the you
could if you would learn
to change the cameras on your machine and make bigger screws around then
maybe you need bigger ones to work in the new kid with a smile and fabric that tried that on
the machine that ran on three pieces an hour. That was really grasp of the new time.
I mean year after year that Arnie just time those
things and if you were next to somebody someone crying or they hollered you were downstairs having
a small whatever you were doing on that front your machine was running it was
no
problem. All right that clown.
Screwed. My ass. I don't know if you'd call it the five thousand by the school
but a different kind of I said it was higher level but the thread was on the outside and it was a
real crisis of course that I would say it was
about six inches long. Maybe longer but it was hard just
a peaceable it looked like a piece of rope. And then the thread was cut but the thread
was really outside of
seventy five between and just and then it wouldn't burn
or nothing you could just see this coming in that red letter hundred or a little
tiny ones you
know and your plants and real fast not the kind of monotonous to
me with. No I have no
idea who was doing the rounds that was for some more material of some kind I
suppose I don't.
Rat
I think our eyes.
To bilk I like I like places. One things to do but I don't like such
a constant rush. Like in the student ever is growing in such a
great little place crying just to admire a minute then rather going
there faster than we are.
And it's too big and I think nobody knew each other there they didn't trust anybody and I
lived in that one and I knew one family in the apartment building that's actually good for them
changed over so fast they'd either move for their job or something going on
and
I do I just don't like it I don't like when I have to be closed up an apartment in our party.
Not bad for coffee I don't like to mix and keep bothering our bombing
our
time but if Iraq or if I'm sick I
like to they haven't seen me for Raaz not that the dry run how are you or good morning
or something I don't
like to be in a place where nobody says good morning or put by a good night or nothing.
You know I
just I'm not that kind of a person I like people and I like to be friendly with people I
don't like to be called in and I'm hearing a lot I mean knowing your and that talk to me a
big city is because they don't know
and don't care and I For that let's just call on then like I said
for now married in the same house I'm living in
now and I know my neighbors coming and going.
You know if you've been in the
situation.
With only one or
two months I didn't I didn't even know I had gullible I
just had a couple of higher taxes back
there and I asked when I got this heart
attack because I never complained about food or
anything and my daughter and myself on them back.
I was asking her back because that's how gall bladder
attack. And because the doctors at that time doctors the stuff
coming to the home. So they had him when he was there about three o'clock in
the mining on that knowledge ladder so that
after that I went to the
clinic. Traumatic bad right of return never knew I had and then I didn't have any storms or
anything and it was just I had so many attacks not knowing what they were and so that's
what was giving me the trouble was the adhesions that had been left
on the attack. To that
other people. And to allow to put me on
a diet for me to lose either way
I was forced to lose forty
pounds and I stayed on is that where you had to because
otherwise really good sex from a lot of that food like any product or anything with
a kernel like anything with a
house and. I had
lost her. Last thirty five or thirty three pounds and I
just couldn't. This was like the mayor and you know.
Take until I thought that the last four times I had about thirty three or thirty
five and I went and I told them to pack or you have to take it out now or forget
i family.
Didn't really have to but you know you were to the degree to be honest and I figured this was a really good
stuff took it out and I had no problem I
was up and added real quick.
You know you.
I just. I would pass that bread I'd
never really rest.
And then when they told me that or there's going to be nothing out right now and they're just
really cocky and greater than and then when she came out I thought Oh my goodness
do automatic surgery they have lived in and battled present battles
I.V.'s and everything and I just thought Oh my goodness today everybody come out of surgery looking back but I
have never
been battling. That had had surgery I had never seen anybody come out of surgery.
So I'll just assume when you came out of the out operating room you were had they were given your blood
and I.D.'s and everything and I just wasn't going to do that I just figured I wasn't sick enough
to procure what I thought I was seeing.
So that when they talked to me they told me I had it was wrong with her and I had they had done to
her and they said well my nose can be nothing like that one
that I run in and I read fine when I came out in fact.
It put me in the same room with that woman because it was right next to the desk for intensive
care and I got out of bed. That evening
and I had scolded for that and as we said
we're back to Iraq to the bathroom and they said it's
our right that was in there that Alex let me call the nurse.
They're not to go on this so what did you do you were driving a battle I said are going get excited is here I
got a phone on the door.
But you sure are weak but you can start rocking and I'm propounding there was something from that from my bed
all the way Brad
saw it but it wasn't bad.
And that's the worst. Now I'm a
diabetic and I don't like being a diabetic.
And I'm not forced to but I do and cheating all the time in the ass not bread.
I don't seem to have the
world not to do it.
When you were sick. Or did your
mother or
to me or the call the doctor who can afford it. My mother was a widow she could
not afford
a headache but I can remember my mother Raqi I never had a headache but my
sister used to get them and my mother used to take
arrive and depart and been a grand lot of warm water and
vinegar and they have been eagerly to regret asking my sister to this day I said that that's already.
Directed this day
something about that vinegar she said I love the smell of and dryers are all wrapped
and she says little.
The afternoon. What
about two
feet.
I ran them through the step grass when I was little I have chubby
and rational and cheerful. So I never really asked my sister a sex
slave
but she wasn't that kind of a
clean.
Sister. You
know and that's fine but really when we had a quarrel. It was never caught Sarah personal economy.
Or warn me
off and I mean it was less just ordinary stuff and we just used to go to
bed and just it just kind of behavior
catalyze then he just some of that kind of stuff can keep you warm or stressed
or curb our. Make you feel high
or something but never really
on medications
lose.
Or lemon and. I lemon into you but because my mother's percent brazenness Honey
I
don't know.
You
know I never
took. Going
to.
I was in line I was a little scared. Already as we went
up
to Bear River and then to
the train and he had a little religious car. And the
Willis. I remember that.
They're willing to have my mother
and my sister and myself that my son and my
father's girlfriend and I sat
in them just the rumble seat.
And we went to Mass on time and it was late when there's something on
my name. So my clothes off and I ran back to the
rumble and were slowed way down. We're late. We're tired and have
a plane that
crashed and you know for cell asleep.
We were all I can remember northern in them to the name of the people with
the cavern store like the all you know in the country are they have a combination of everything.
And people fighting the T.V.
doing that and writing I was like I say I
was asleep like my rest of them in the front
seat and the woman was no more than when we came
she just jumped him out for tight entire jury and he went in the ditch. But
she landed right on
the foot of the car. And she died
but from the day we come through and of the mention.
But she was drunk and her and her husband were fighting and the sheriff said it was sad
but they
knew they raided every day. For cars because they were fighting so bad
and in fact when they went to find her husband he was sleeping in the woods should they have had just a big plate to
do
for that little bit. And she decided she just had my son and nothing
else just that night down on.